hey this is preshtalwalker
abcd is a rectangle
point p is 11 units from a 13 units from
b and 7 units from c
what is the distance from p to d
note
the point p could either be inside the
rectangle
or it could also be outside the
rectangle
a variant of this problem was asked as
an interview question at microsoft
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
there's a special equation that always
works for rectangles and a given point p
it doesn't matter whether the point is
inside the rectangle or outside the
rectangle
it is always true that ap squared plus
cp squared is equal to bp squared plus
dp squared
in other words
the sum of the squared distances from p
to a set of opposite corners of the
rectangle is equal to the same sum of
the square distances of p to the other
set of opposite corners in the rectangle
this equation will make quick work of
the problem
we were given that ap equals 11 bp
equals 13 and cp equals 7.
we can substitute those values into our
equation
and then we can simplify it and then
solve the dp must be equal to one
so this is a fantastic formula because
we can figure out the distance to the
fourth corner from knowing the distances
to the other three corners and we don't
need to know whether p is inside the
rectangle or outside the rectangle and
we don't know anything about the
rectangle like its length and width we
can still figure out the distance from p
to the fourth corner of the rectangle
now this is a rarely taught equation
but it has a kind of interesting name
we could represent it geometrically as
follows
we have ap squared which we can
represent as an area
that's a square
cp squared we can also draw a square
for the other distances we'll draw them
as red squares
for this equation to be true
it means that the total area of the blue
squares is equal to the total area of
the red squares
now this diagram has a vague resemblance
to the union jack and so this is
actually known as the british flag
theorem it's rarely taught in school but
as we'll see it's actually an extension
of the pythagorean theorem
so now let's prove why this equation is
true
we'll start out with the rectangle and
we'll put point p inside the rectangle
the proof will be similar when p is
outside the rectangle
so now we'll draw
all of the distances from the corners to
the point p
what we'll do is we'll draw a vertical
line that's perpendicular to c d and a b
that runs through p
we'll label the intersections as e and f
we're now going to write in some
variables for the distances
we'll say that the horizontal distance
from a to p is equal to w
the horizontal distance from b to p is
equal to x
we'll then say the vertical distance
from a to p is equal to y
and the vertical distance from p to d is
equal to z
so because this is a rectangle
we can actually label some of the other
lengths in this figure
we know
that df will also be equal to w
and cf will also be equal to x
so now where does this get us
well you can see that we have four right
triangles that involve the four
distances to p that we want
so we can figure out the squared
distances using the pythagorean theorem
ap squared will be equal to w squared
plus y squared
bp squared will be equal to x squared
plus y squared
cp squared will be equal to x squared
plus z squared
and then dp squared will be equal to w
squared plus z squared
now if you add up the variables
correctly
it is obvious that ap squared plus cp
squared is equal to bp squared plus dp
squared because both of them will be
equal to x squared plus y squared plus w
squared plus z squared
thus we've proven the british flag
theorem
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description